yoda guerre bonjour cet appel d'offres
sap a trompé frayer ait eu quoi quand
même
le leader mondial du jeu tous étaient
qui veut rénover sur vieux manoir pour
en faire un lieu dédié au plaisir du jeu
ça ne doit pas vous arriver tous les
jours dans votre agence je me trompe
venue alors le manoir daguerre salle
gars ça peut-être passé cette fois-ci
vous êtes en pleine réunion de famille
le vendredi je l'aide à guerre c'est ma
vie les ravages et enchanté
vous avez 5 chance sur 6 gagnez vous
avez l'appel d'offres ou fichez moi
c'est de l'humour bon c'est l'humour de
papa mais cet amour
imart
et je suis parmi vous c'est que le
démasque pas
salomi tour la
paire
calories brûlées
amusez vous bien
un tueur fou dans la maison et vous vous
allez le jouer à des jeux je veux pas qu
humain
je crois que ça existe une famille
normale
vous êtes juste après vivant du
contraire
[Musique]
vous voulez pas jouer